hello everyone and welcome
i'm jacqueline goldsby i'm chair of the
african american studies department
and i'm really really excited to see so
many of you uh here in our zoom room
uh for our final session of the
department's colloquium series uh which
we call endeavors
and this uh semester we've been devoting
our thinking to
the idea the theme of black now
conversations for the revolution um
i want to say a little bit about where
we've been so far to kind of frame where
we're going to
land uh today and also to give thanks to
the
the people the staff who've organized us
for these past three months
so over these three months we've been
able to engage the vital issues facing
black americans and indeed all
americans as we've braced ourselves
through a time
unlike any other right in the context of
a global pandemic
and a presidential election that tested
the limits of american democracy itself
the stakes of what it means to secure
voting rights and to turn back voter
suppression could never have been
higher than now the stakes of organizing
health care delivery as a right
and practice for justice couldn't be
higher than they are right now
and the stakes of producing art that
could sustain critical hope
in beloved community couldn't be higher
than now
and the stakes of devising policies and
activist programs that could dismantle
the carceral state
its agencies its agents and the culture
that sustains it
so that we so that black lives could
thrive and matter at the same time
all of these issues have been absolutely
at the forefront of our thinking this
term
and we've been very fortunate to have a
series of
activists artists and scholars come and
talk to us about these very issues
and so i want to thank those who have
been in the zoo room before
today latasha brown amy cox
emily wang dwayne betts titus kaffar
claudia rankin philip gough philip
mccaris
and today's speakers who will be
introduced to you in just a few minutes
seconds really i want to thank them all
for
sharing their wisdom sharing their work
doing the work and giving us the
challenge of
asking ourselves what is to be done and
what can we do
to advance the cause of justice if you
want to see these video
these uh talks we've posted them um
and this is why you're being recorded
today you can access
these earlier discussions on the african
american studies department's website
go to the videos tab and you can learn a
lot
about what we've been thinking about
this past semester
i want to thank the staff that's helped
us organize
these conversations i first of all want
to thank our co-sponsors
uh the center for the study of race and
degenerate
indigeneity and transnational migration
uh the director's
professor stephen pitty and the
assistant director matthew taniko have
been
absolutely brilliant and wonderful and
supporting
us to organize this series
including um the whole process of
getting the videos mounted through
yale's youtube channel i never knew how
much work that entailed
and stephen and matthew have been really
supportive in that
um vanessa epps our newest staff member
in the african-american studies
department has been a tireless
pr engine for this series and i really
want to thank her for her work and
getting the word out
um i want to thank emmanuel basell who's
been our technical support these last
three months and making sure that the
zoom room
runs efficiently and that no connections
are dropped
it's been amazing um and last but
certainly not least
i want to thank professor crystal
themester whose
absolute acute intelligence
has uh she's curated the series with it
with a kind of
verve and insight and energy and care
that has really really been remarkable
i've learned so much because of her
so i just want to thank crystal and the
staff for all of their work
so with that i will turn it over to
professor thiemster who will introduce
our
guest today thank you so much
um jackie um as always for bringing us
into the space with such profound words
and acknowledgement um of the work that
we do
and the work that still needs to be done
in these days
where everybody is thinking about
the fragility of black life um i wanted
to add
my thanks to yours i'm not going to name
everybody
that you did but i do want to again
think thank vanessa
apps who has been my right hand um
in this whole process of bringing
everybody together in this endeavor
series
moreover i want to thank all of my
colleagues none of this would have been
possible
without folks agreeing um to show up and
to show out in many ways whether
as interlocutors for the conversations
are
as the keynote um and
so i want to thank everybody for their
part
in making this happen um on that note i
do want to get us started
um we have a little bit of time here we
want to make the most of it
um and i want to just for those of you
who are new to the format
i'm just going to sort of reiterate what
the format is before i introduce our
three
speakers today um we as as
professor girls be mentioned we're
recording the these
and we really want to try to keep as
many people out of the frame as
possible besides our speakers
and so we will start um with
our interlock locker gwen prowse will
kick us off
um at um one at 12 45
we will open up for q a but we do it
in the zoom way um and we will ask that
you send your questions
to gwen prowse in the private chat she
will curate the q a
um and make sure that all your questions
are addressed
and and i know what they will be
answered brilliantly by
elizabeth and tracy um i will remind you
in the chat oh we've reached that time
so please send your questions to gwen um
and then gwen will will
will present this to the presenters we
end at 1 15
um so we won't be holding people over um
so on that note let me begin by
introducing
some of my favorite people um friends
and colleagues um
tracy meers first who i've known for
since the day i arrived here and has
welcomed
me into the community of scholars here
at yale and my family into the community
of new
haven and i always be grateful for that
tracy meers is the walton hill
hamilton professor and founding director
of the justice collaboratory at yale law
school
before joining yale she was a professor
at the university of chicago law school
from 1995 to 2007.
she was the first african-american woman
granted tenure at both law schools
meers is nationally recognized expert on
policing in urban communities
who has worked extensively with the
federal government including being a
member of president barack obama's task
force
on 21st century policing in 2019
mears was elected a member of the
american academy of arts and sciences
my colleague elizabeth hinton is an
associate professor
in the department of history and the
department of african american studies
at yale
and i hope like tracy welcomed me i hope
that i'll be a person who can
help you and your family adjust to life
in new haven in the post government
moment
it's just been so hard um at this at
this time but i hope you know
that um the department um and all of us
are really pleased to have you
among us and can't wait to sort of
meet your daughter and hang out over
drinks in person
um so um hinton's research focuses on
the persistence of poverty
racial inequality and urban violence on
the in the 21st century united states
she is considered one of the nation's
leading experts on criminalization and
policing
in her book from the war on poverty to
the war on crime
the making of mass incarceration in
america published by harvard university
press
hinton examines the implementations of
federal law enforcement programs
beginning in the mid-1960s that
transformed the domestic social policies
and lay the groundwork for the expansion
of the u.s prison system
and my students spread about three
chapters of um
from the world poverty in my long civil
rights course this year and it really
made a difference kind of changing
the way that i organized that course in
the way it ends
um so i'm particularly grateful for that
work um
so thank you elizabeth and also finally
but not least
i'm happy to introduce um gwen prowse
who is one of our amazing phd candidates
in the political science and african
american studies
department um gwen has become one of
those people that
i often call on to do extra work
um no matter what kind of um
series or workshop i'm working with
i always think of her and her work the
kind of intersectional work that she's
doing interdisciplinary work that she's
doing
and so i'm especially grateful because i
think this is the second
request that i've made of her to
participate
in one of the workshops or series that
i've been a part of this year so
nothing but gratitude to you gwen and
gwen
um focuses her up the focus of her
research is grassroots
political mobilization in u.s cities her
work in multi-methods
and aims to involve community members in
every step of the research process
she is a research fellow with the
institute for social policy studies
and an affiliate with the justice
collaboratory at the yale law school
she is a co-pi with vesla weaver and
tracy mears
for the portals policing project which
examines how police
citizens police and citizens
interactions shape political knowledge
and political discourse in majority
black communities in the
in the united states thank you all and
i'm going to turn it over to gwen
thank you so much professor feemster can
everyone hear me
okay great um thank you professor
keemster and thank you professor gold c
vanessa epps and our partners at ritm
um i'm deeply honored to be moderating
today's discussion between
two scholars who i admire so much
that were ending this semester's
endeavor series and conversation with
professor mears
and professor hinton could not be more
appropriate
professor mears is the co-founder of the
justice collaboratory
four out of the six speakers of this
semester series are active
members of this group dwayne betts dr
emily wang professor philip etiba goth
and of course professor hinton
together collaboratory members
demonstrate how health
safety art and education and the many
ways in which they intersect
and overlap are foundational to a future
where black freedom is possible where a
third reconstruction
is on its way from their standpoints and
expertise
they name that the steps on the way
toward revolution
are both complicated and absolutely
necessary
and urgent they don't just study these
ideas they push them toward policy
many demand that those most intimately
affected by the carcero state
participate and lead meanwhile
professor hinton's work as a 20th
century historian reminds us
that this type of work is not new that
reckonings have happened before
and in the not so distant past that
waves of democratization in the u.s have
coincided the growth
in surveillance punishment and control
of black and indigenous peoples and
migrants
in her articles books and op-eds
professor hinton reminds us that the
bold recommendations of the kerner
commission in 1968
following the wave of urban rebellions
in response to police violence
reminds us how the fear of white racism
quotes fomenting domestic turmoil
led to liberal policymakers distancing
themselves from these very
recommendations
this may sound tragically familiar to
discourse today
but today i'm so excited to talk to
these two scholars and bring them in
conversation with one another
for all of the tireless work they're
doing
to reverse that course of history in
collaboration with others community and
many scholars
so i'm going to begin first with um
with the topic of the justice
collaboratory um and if
professor mears you'd like to begin just
to talk a little bit about the
collaboratory
it's genesis um and then professor
hinton if you would like to talk a bit
about the work that
um you've come to do within that space
a mute it only took nine months
to figure out how to do that at the
beginning before one speaks
right um thanks so much for the
introduction for having
us um and for the opportunity to be
among friends at the end of the semester
also that 56 of you
turned out on what is essentially close
to the last day of semester is pretty
impressive so
thanks for that the collaboratory's
origin
is in a social science
research project essentially um a
collaboration
um between the center for policing
equity i think i saw
phil at boteva goff somewhere in this
zoom room
um when he was at ucla um
and some folks at john jay came together
to
put together a demonstration project
that was funded
uh by the department of justice to bring
together our various research
streams and come up with
some policy approaches
to you know see if we could make
some kind of a difference you know it
wasn't
an attempt to fundamentally reconceive
safety as we understand it should happen
but certainly
an opportunity to bring science to
policy
which is um an important thing that the
collaboratory has stood for
as i think many have noted and
many members of the collaboratory have
noted that too often
policy is
has no theory and certainly has very
little
evidence and we like to proceed from the
standpoint
that you know evidence is a set of facts
and offered
that are offered in answer to a question
and one doesn't know what questions to
ask
unless one is actually appropriately
guided by theory
what works is not a real question right
um so that was the beginning and you
know with
that what those initial resources we
were able
to put together um and attract
a group of incredible people who are
interested in working on this project
uh broadly conceived and so today i
would say
you know we're much more forward-looking
in their
um in terms of not just
thinking about in an emergency context
in extremis
what are some things one could do to
and in policy terms to make
existing organization systems and the
like less harmful but
um trying to work out much more uh
a a a thick and broad theory of what
brought community
vitality means um and how that
is centered around concepts of
justice and and the last thing i'll say
is i don't want to go on blah blah blah
but once you take seriously the idea
of community vitality as a goal
then one understands that one
must center the people whose
safety demands are relevant to said
policy
right um and that seems like a really
simple thing
um an obvious thing um to do
but as we've seen historically as i'm
sure elizabeth will discuss
those constant efforts at doing that
have have been
derailed and i think it's our hope that
we can you know try once again
to to deepen and center and provide a
more robust multi-disciplinary
theoretical framework around that
approach
um before i talk about the collaboratory
i also want to thank
um crystal and and gwen for those uh
really tremendous introductions thank
you um
thank all of you for coming and of
course it's an honor to be
in conversation with uh with tracy i'm
really looking forward to it and this
um also is kind of like my first uh big
public
appearance as a yale faculty member
which is um really exciting for me
i um i just arrived here in the summer
but i've been on leave this term
um madly finishing up a book manuscript
which maybe i'll talk about some
later um and excited to be fully on next
term and begin
um teaching here and so this is um
this is i i'm just excited for this
because i it's part of my kind of like
welcome into the community so thank you
um so actually i mean a big pull for me
coming to yale was to be a part of the
justice collaboratory and of course
um the african-american studies
department and among
um in conversations with scholars whose
work i really admire
but what the justice laboratory has
increasingly done i think um
too with the addition of um of phil goff
as tracy mentioned is really bringing
together
um an interdisciplinary group of
scholars who
is attempting to tackle and make
meaningful changes
in um the kind of landscape of safety
and um
and criminal justice today and i think
the community
centered model um through which much of
the justice collaboratory's work is done
is really inspirational to me and i
think
um what is what is going to be key if we
are too as
as as jackie mentioned at the outset you
know dismantle
um the cultural state and and and
institutions which have
um really functioned as the engine of
racial inequality post-civil rights
um i i'm kind of coming in hitting the
ground running in some senses because
i'm working with dwayne betts who um you
heard from
earlier this term um the amazing poet
and um and legal scholar um who
is who and this is this is totally
dwayne's
you know brainchild an idea and i i'm
just kind of here supporting him um
but he is directing the million books
projects which um
which will institute um 500
uh book capsules into um
into prisons and juvenile detention
facilities um
across the united states and puerto rico
and this is an incredibly ambitious
project right because it's seeking to
give prisoners access to an entirely
different
set of um of reading materials and
educational
materials that they that they don't have
access to in the sense that
most prison libraries you know they it's
like full of
like tom clancy novels and really really
outdated
um pieces of literature and so duane um
is going to really transform the the
kind of landscape of what
the kinds of reading materials that
prisoners have access to and it's
um it's a combination of the 500 books
we're still in the process of choosing
what they're
going to be and this actually has been
um the project launched this summer
and it's you know it's a big task to
figure out like what 500 books
um we think you know kind of like best
represent what needs to be
um in prisons across the united states
today so we're still
finalizing the list actually and meeting
with dwayne right after this to
to talk about that but it's a
combination of literature
and um and history and political science
and sociology
um that will really give provide a new
kind of robust curriculum inside prisons
and
you know in itself as a kind of um
established library we hope that it'll
um help foster discussion and and
community organizing and mobilization
inside
um inside prisons and so far you know
we've just been
we don't have the 500 books finalized
but in just a few months
we've already got several thousand books
into 80 different prisons in 30
different states so
already this project is making a
humongous difference um
in the lives of people who are
incarcerated in the middle of the clovid
19 pandemic which is
literally wreaking havoc um inside the
nation's prison system
um and just one last plug on that um
dwayne and um and elsa hardy who
actually was a student of mine
it is a phd student of mine at harvard
i'm her advisor
who's now a first year student at yale
law school elsa and duane
are are hosting a podcast
featuring authors who are included in
the collection and this podcast will be
available to the public but it also um
be available inside prison so
um look out for that and this is just
one example to mention the last thing
that
the justice laboratory housed the
million the million book books project
but it was made possible by
a humongous 5 million grant from the
mellon foundation and so
this is just one example of the kinds of
programs
that the justice collaboratory supports
and the kinds of real
difference um the collaboratory is
making in terms of the landscape
of incarceration and also policing and
public safety and community vitality as
tracy mentioned
thank you so much to both for providing
an overview of the origin of the justice
collaboratory and also
one of the specific and crucial projects
that's taking place
right now tracy you
um you said earlier if community
vitality
is the goal one must center the people
whose safety demands
are relevant to policy can you talk a
little bit
about what that looks like
in research in research or within the
collaboratory so what is it
what does it mean to center those whose
safety demands are most relevant to
policy
in social science research or legal
research and perhaps
elizabeth in the archives
so let me give you two examples of how
you might go about doing it
um and then let me say something about
what it's not
um and then let me say something about
what i don't know yet
okay so point one
how you do it um the first example i
would point to
is our own project ms prowse which is
the
portals policing project um
if you google portals
portalpolicingproject.com
you can actually see
what we've done we've again taken an art
project actually it's an art
installation
promoted by shared studios where people
are able to connect with one another
through some pretty sophisticated tech
so think
full body zoom in a golden shipping
container
where members of
communities that we try to identify some
that
where people experience um higher
than what is average we'll call it
um impacts of violence whether we're
talking about
interpersonal violence or police
violence
right and ask them about their
experience with both violence
and police and the state's response to
it generally
by listening to those conversations
one can easily ascertain that
what i would call stakeholders right
people who experience both the problems
that the state typically sends general
purpose armed first responders to
address
how they deal with both those problems
and the state response and their own
conception
of what they think the state's response
should be understand
importantly that their own conception of
what the state's response should be
isn't necessarily a conversation about
how police how the policing service as
we know it
could and should be different although
there is some of that it's
literally a conversation about what the
state's response should be and in a lot
of the work that i'm doing myself
which is relevant to the my 0.3 i don't
know yet
um is it thinking very seriously about a
set of public goods
the state's provision of public goods
what the police power means in that
context and
that is a term of art everyone so police
power in law
is not the policing pa service that
as we know it the police power is the
state's
ability to regulate um
and support health order and such for
its citizens so
any state response to the pandemic right
now
like vaccinations or or more generally
requiring that people go to public
schools
for example and get a certain level of
education that's actually an exercise of
the police power
we can come back to that later um but in
any case
um that's one way to do it um another
way to do it
is to is to invest really
heavily in um
what uh the term of art is cb par it
it's community based approaches to
research where you
actually design research projects in
collaboration with
the members of the communities with whom
you're working
and and and studying that's much more
common in medicine
although even in medicine that is
you know on the fringe frankly
emily wong does a lot of this work who
is also a collaboratory
member elizabeth and i are actually
partnering with emily
right now on on a project
and concerning covid detections
in incarcerating incarceration settings
as well as developing protocols for
vaccination and who gets vaccinations
first by actually again centering people
who are affected people who are in the
incarcerative settings that's
a cb par approach
one of the things that we're very
interested in doing in the collaboratory
is doing more of that work
cb par approaches on the social science
side
um it's difficult to do because
foundations don't
typically pay for it right and so
you know trying to figure out how to
design those kinds of things
are difficult so that's one answer how
um what it's not what it's not is
thinking about a top-down approach to
for example when you think about safety
saying
well you know homicide rates are high
the best way to approach homicide rates
are
sending more police armed first
responders to dealing with it this is
what
um mayor bloomberg and ray kelly did in
new york
and you should be grateful that fewer
people
are being killed because we have decided
what the the best approach is or to put
it differently
i'll use a kind of outside example um
think about um online interaction social
media
the justice collaboratory also has a
whole thing that we do
on in the social media space actually um
and you know that approach would be to
say
that the best way to have health on in
the social media is just to
focus on content moderation and rule
violations
rather than to take an approach where
you could seriously
um think through the architecture of
interaction
that people have in that space and think
about it in a healthful way
right don't ban cars because cars are
dangerous figure out how to have better
lighting on the streets
have rumble strips on streets
take curves out of roads right so that
people can have
egress in a more healthful way right
that's
two ways of thinking about it here's
what i don't know point three
um we started out talking about um you
know a more robust theory of
community vitality which i think is a
center
part of achieving justice because
so many people have been involved so
long in the negative project
you know figuring out articulations of
a theoretical approach to that other
than
something like you know everybody should
have equal capacity
to fulfill their goals and projects you
know
that's a goal but it's sort of not like
a robust theory of
of how to do it what it means how you
study it
um that's the part i don't know and so
you know one small thing i'm doing
is to think about for example the police
power
and and recover that as
something that that's positive that
citizens deserve
that citizens deserve to have their
state working for them
and providing a set of public goods
um for flourishing
yeah just continuing i mean some of some
of the the the issues that tracy raised
i mean i think so much of it
has to do with the um the voices that we
choose to privilege and center and i
think that
goes into the ways in which we um that
we read
the archive and it's really difficult um
you know the archive does not
often capture the most um marginalized
and oppressed voices and i think
especially uh when it comes to policing
and crime control in low-income
communities of color
in the late 20th and early 21st century
it's um
it's really difficult which is part of
the reason why
a lot of the interpretation that we have
that is um
based in archival sources does tend to
privilege a narrative that
um that that talks about the
the the kind of the demands for law and
order tougher sentencing
more police um that were emerging from
communities that were over police
especially
um by the time we get to the war on
drugs in the 1980s
but i think there is a different way to
read that and to read the sets of
demands that people are making
in the portals project but also in the
1960s the
project that i'm working on right now um
considers
uh black rebellion from the
you know mid-60s really to the present
and
um and especially in the kind of six the
late 60s early 70s 68 to 72 period that
we don't really think about
and the and my kind of you know primary
source space for this work
are newspapers um archival records of
radical
civil rights and black power
organizations that were working on
anti-police issues and oral histories
and you know there are even within the
newspapers right
you you can if you privilege the the
voices and perspectives of those people
who participated who resorted to
uh political violence in order to make a
set of demands on the state if you
privilege their perspectives and their
demands
and actually take seriously when they
say you know we want
we don't want to live in shacks anymore
we don't want rats and roaches in our
apartments we want
new kinds of investment we want jobs the
kids don't have summer jobs in our
communities
these are the demands that where people
were making and an
incident of police violence and ended up
usually being the precipitating incident
so
you know very often we kind of focus on
the
on the um the material results instead
of actually
centering the people who are in the
ground zero of where um
where these repressive measures are
implemented so i think a lot of it
has to do with like who we who we choose
to privilege and how seriously
we take the demands of um
of of people who are living in
communities that are over police and
underprotected and under resourced
and i think because of the position of
many of the people
living in these communities they're
often not really listened to
and as tracy mentioned you know the
response the immediate knee-jerk
response historically
ends up being um more police and this
gets into
something that um uh an idea that i've
developed with um
with just a laboratory member and former
yale professor who's now at johns
hopkins uh bachelor weaver and julie
kohler houseman who's a historian at
cornell that's called selective hearing
and um we wrote an op-ed in new york
times about this and
one of the things that we argue is that
you know like we asked the question like
why is it that despite like all
of the demands that black people make on
this date like the only demand that gets
consistently taken up is like policing
sentencing prisons etc and so
you know we call this concept selective
hearing because when black communities
are saying we want better policing
you know what tracy's talking about like
we want protection we want the state to
work for us we want
uh control over what public safety in
our communities look like
instead of like actually giving that
right what what policymakers and
politicians and law enforcement
officials here is okay better police and
that means more policing so again it's
like the selective hearing concept and i
think
one of the key challenges and it is
really a challenge i think um
you know a lot of the responses to the
protest this summer and the kind of um
the the the robust national discussions
about police brutality that emerged you
know it really shows is that you know
this is not
um you know the selected hearing is
still going on and people are still not
being
listened to and we're at a moment when
um
in order to achieve the kind of
community vitality that tracy is talking
about
um these perspectives really really need
to be um
to ground any kind of uh change moving
forward
um thank you so much for those responses
and i think this
this point about selective hearing and
in the policy making process
um leads me to ask another question that
i wanted to bring to both of you today
which is
you know both of you have served in
various kind of policy making
public capacities outside using your
work as scholars to inform
the policy making process at the local
level and at the national level
i know tracy you've served on the
president's task force
on 21st century policing you're now on
the board of police commissioners
in new haven and then elizabeth i
understand you've done
some work in stockton california so
something that
i'm i'd love to hear from both of you
and you know maybe maybe elizabeth you'd
like to start first
since uh you know what have you learned
about
institutions in the process of serving
in these
roles and how
yeah how have you been able to
contribute uh
contribute your work as a scholar but
also how
has this um you know how has how these
experiences may be
complicated or frustrated what you know
about
um the state uh through your research
that's a great question i'm i'm also um
i'm eager to hear
i'm glad i'm going first because i want
i want i want to know what tracy
tracy's response to what i to what i
have to say um
so yeah as gwen mentioned i've been
working um
for the past wow it's been four years
now with the uh with the police chief of
stockton california eric jones who's um
who's one of the most if not the most
progressive chiefs in the country
he was it's now over was part of um
this this program called national
initiative for safe communities which
um which uh started like kind of a as a
post-ferguson thing at the department of
justice to really implement
um procedural justice uh
tracy's um kind of model for policing
in the in the 21st century in um six
pilot departments um and stockton was
chosen as
um as one of them and uh
i was hooked up with chief jones because
he was really
open to using history um as part of what
he was calling a racial reconciliation
effort between
uh the police department and um and
residents of color in stockton
and he basically you know said you can
have access to
our records um in order to help us
better understand the history of kind of
racialized enforcement and so that we
can use this historical evidence to
ground our discussions moving forward
um stockton's department also had a
really robust procedural justice
training setup and especially
a module within that training that spent
a day looking at the history of racist
law enforcement which um
at least to my knowledge you know the
amount of time
spent on looking at kind of the history
of um
of police oppression of um of black and
brown communities is really kind of
unmatched um
you know they do a day-long training
that goes from you know
slavery and the black codes all the way
up to the modern day
um and this you know a lot of this
information is completely new
for um most of the police officers so
part of my task was to talk to people in
the community and
and um and scour these records to kind
of
uncover various incidents that could be
put at the center of the training
but also in the listening sessions that
were being held between police officers
and
um and and community members and um
you know the idea was in part because a
lot of the
the kind of like the history module
training
was focused on um you know like police
complicity
and and lynchings and other forms of
racial terrorism that seemed
for many officers very far away from
stockton and so this process is ongoing
um but it has been um
i think something that's been you know
really incredible to see
um and even the effort to
uh for these officers to reckon with
this history i think is is really
important and
a step um towards improving
general relations with the community and
and and improving trust which is one of
the kind of um
big principles of of procedural justice
but it's also
you know i think stockton in some ways
um you know
that the pro there are a number of
problems right i mean one is
that even if police administrators buy
in
to this kind of uh these kinds of
discussions and
um and the idea of racial reconciliation
if you want to call it that
um there is a disconnect between the you
know administrators like chief jones and
scott madors who who does the um
the the history module training and the
rank and file officers so
there's not necessarily you know what's
required is a is a humongous cultural
shift to get rank and file to really buy
in
and to really um begin to change the
ways in which they patrol
targeted um mexican american and and and
black communities in stockton
and it's also you know as part of that
work too
i last year i um i
was a instructor in a in the california
command college where basically police
administrators
um you know go to they do like a month
several month long intensive um
educational immersion experience and so
i came in one day to talk about
um racism and policing and it was a
really for me
a really like intense and informative
experience and i realized then that like
so
many you know even in this moment when
and it's not just chief jones right you
have
um former uh heads of the international
association of chief of
police and and police chiefs around the
country you know beginning to apologize
for things like lynching and beginning
to say
we need to listen to community in new
ways we need to reckon with
um the history of police violence
especially
directed against people of color um
again a lot of other administrators a
lot of rank and file think it's complete
bs they think it actually prevents them
from being able to do their jobs they
think that
um you know in many senses like any
any kind of police reform um especially
one that
is you know kind of centered in notions
of racial justice
um you know doesn't allow them to to
perform their duties as police officers
as they see fit so
you know on the one hand i you know i go
to stockton and i'm
i'm you know i we have a great listening
session or there's a really powerful
training
and i'm feeling like okay you know this
is like planting the seeds of change
it's not necessarily the end of itself
and then like i go down to san diego to
do this training
and i'm hearing you know a bunch of
other police administrators say this is
complete
bs and um and we can't do our jobs
because
we're scared of being called racists and
this and you know
knowing this history doesn't help us do
police work in the present
so um we still have a very long way
to go
it's funny you said you wanted to hear
what i had to say i mean i'm like well
you know welcome to my life
[Laughter]
what have i been doing for the last
decade i mean
you know i i think um
i think being a lawyer makes
it easier for me to sit
with that disjuncture um
you know because i have my theoretical
goals
i have the stuff that i do and the
day-to-day
to both just make what exists
less harmful because we're an extremist
but also um you know like you said inch
forward but also i think being a lawyer
i have a really much more detailed sense
of all the ways in which it's hard which
are not just about
people's psychology not just about the
ways in which
organizational forms cause people as a
psychological matter to just sort of
like try to get through their day
you know like part of what you're
talking about when people say
this doesn't make my job any easier is
just the day-to-day
most people in their day-to-day just
you know want their day to be as easy as
possible
it's the status quo and not they're not
actually trying to challenge themselves
and
and change and i'm not saying that in a
negative way i'm just being
descriptive right um for most people
they don't want to get up and be like
what's the hardest thing i can do today
you know that's just not what people do
right
um and then you add to that the way
government works
in this country um
federalism is a huge issue
i mean and and i actually think
for for folks you know i'm sure most
educated people are just aware of it but
you know when you actually do not study
it you don't
understand the complexities
that that governmental arrangement
gives you okay so you know i've
done the federal president's task force
um you know i also just got off of uh
a statewide force to
re to think about how post
should change its training for the new
connecticut use of force statute which
which has its own federalism issues
given that
there are gazillion tiny little cities
in this state
um and no regional government and like
you know
managing those people to raise them to a
basic floor
is very difficult and um
on tuesday night i sat for two hours
as a commissioner on the new haven board
of police commissioners
you know where we had the beginnings of
you know we had a discussion about the
relationship between the new haven
police department
and yale's police department which of
course is intimately tied up
in the fact that this university
doesn't have to pay state taxes and that
the city is under resourced and so
how you think about delivering safety to
people
in this city um who are right now
how many times have i used the word
extremists
the homicide rate today in new haven is
double
this year what it was last year
shootings are up by 85
okay um so in a context like that
when people are saying to folks in the
city
take away the one thing that you
believe i'm not saying they're right
it's like what they believe
you know the one thing that you believe
is making you safer that is
you know reduce the number of
yale police officers who can enforce the
law when people
in this community think that makes them
safer and in some cases i think they're
right
you know when the yale police department
handles
20 000 calls for service per year
that the new haven police department
would otherwise have to handle
and doesn't have the resources it's a
complex
issue it's just really complex and so
you know there are no easy answers here
let me give you one more example
of the ways in which federalism works in
minneapolis
for example there is currently a
proposal
um to take away somewhere between
seven million or eight million dollars
of the police budget
and devote it to other things right um
one of the calls is well let's take
eight million dollars of the
of the police budget and send it and
give it to
mental health okay fine guess what in
minneapolis mental health services are
provided at the county level
which is a different tax structure so
it is not just the case
that you're going to take money from the
city budget and give it to
the county in fact everybody understands
that that's not what's going to happen
um and so then the idea is well let's
just build out
the city's public health service to do
more of this work
well okay maybe but like why would you
do that when the county
is already doing this and eight million
dollars isn't enough
to provide right so this
ish is really hard
and it is a mistake to underestimate how
hard it is
that doesn't mean that we shouldn't be
working on it like can i show you my
gray hair
um but um
like it takes a lot it's not just about
a theory and it's not just
not just about asking
communities what they need and want
which i do think is the
the first step right there's all of that
and then there's the governance problem
which
is prodigious
thank you both for those answers um
and uh the government as a political
scientist the governance problem
um is is something that i
um unfortunately think about a lot too
um i um
speaking speaking of um conversations
that are happening at the community
level
um questions uh and
this this question of what do we do with
city budgets state county federal
budgets um
to keep people safe um i wanna i i
i'm gonna have my last question before
um
i bring in other voices
from this group be about your article
in the atlantic with tom tyler tracy
um
i'm going to read a quote real quick
from this article
so you say if america is to move beyond
its troubled and conflict-laden
relationship with its police
it must have a broader serious
discussion
about what democratic policing can and
should be
what are police for this is a moment for
such a discussion
the crime rate has for several several
years now been at historically low
levels
the costs of police community conflict
are once again clear
and in an era of shrinking municipal
budgets the costs of america's current
style of policing
have major effects on the ability of
communities to provide other necessary
public
goods that are building blocks of
vitality
for this discussion to be successful it
must involve the meaningful
participation of all people in america's
communities
so this question um of what is it police
are for
um i'd i'd like for both of you to
reflect on kind of how you are currently
pursuing answers to that question what
might be
your answer today or to whom are
you like most inspired as a voice as a
voice or a set of voices who
are engaging this question of what is it
police are for
elizabeth you want to go first
so i mean i think police as we think
about
police and as we think about police
historically have been
um you know agents of social control
and uh defenders of racial hierarchy and
oppression so i mean that
you know from the early kind of forms
and
and enslaved patrols to the present um
you know they they the the kind of
function of police
um at least as far as poor people go and
people of color
go um have have been historically
um focused more on kind of like
apprehension and identifying suspects
to remove from the community than
necessarily
protecting people in white and middle
class communities
um especially in the 20th century right
um police functions have been
you know primarily about protecting
property so they're so
police in low income community policing
in low-income communities color is
completely different
um than it is in in in middle class
communities and white communities and so
in that sense um you know policing
needs to be fundamentally it needs to
end um as we know it i mean i do
think that we that public safety is
important we need to have a public
safety function
but you know after studying this this
history and
and also centering um you know what
residents them how residents themselves
think about public safety
and the various reforms that had been
suggested historically
you know that that policing doesn't know
that police officer doesn't necessarily
look like
an outsider who comes into a community
who is fearful of the community and who
then in turn
the community is fearful of in a uniform
with a gun
and so that model of public safety um
and i think you know i mean this has
been under discussion
for for for half a century now at least
but i mean certainly
you know in recent years with the kind
of rise of um
the slogan defund the police right we're
beginning to rethink the logics of that
model of um of law enforcement and i
mean just really briefly on on some of
what uh tracy
touched on at the end of her comment i
mean i i think a lot of the proud you
know
one way to think about defund i mean the
way that it's framed is something that's
like negative and taking away
um and that and that i think um
has done some harm to the idea of um
of reconstituting public safety as we
know it and i think one
i think taxes are really important and
one way that we can think about how to
begin
to invest in different models of public
safety and invest
in education and invest in decent
housing and invest in job creation
um which may be the most important thing
is to think about our tax structure
the fact that we have you know like who
gets the biggest welfare in this country
corporations um you know the richest
people in this country actually pay
less taxes in the middle class um the
entire tax structure
makes no sense in the united states and
if we begin to at least
reform that that's going to free up
billions of dollars to begin to spend on
public goods in an entirely different
way
than they have been i mean our tax
structure has kind of like
you know it's become more regressive
coinciding with
um the rise of prisons in this country
so the fact that we tax the way they do
the way we do in the us i think is
reflective of the fact that we are this
mass incarceration society and so
what what d fund is really about for me
and
is asking that the question of what are
police for but also calling on
government authorities to make a
different set of investments
um and i do think historically you know
the federal government has
played an important role in kind of
taking the lead
in protecting um and ensuring various
protections
for especially uh racially people who
are racially oppressed
um but also thinking about ways that we
could redistribute resources and so i
think that it is going to take
um it is going to take a federal
intervention for us to see
these kind of national changes and
transformations that are going to be
necessary if we want to
build um a more equitable society and
and realize the promises of our founding
values and
um you know the civil war reconstruction
amendments
so i don't have a lot to add to that
other than to say
um just to remind everyone this is not
an article it's an essay
i wrote in the atlantic and the reason
why it's important to mention that is
like you have
you have to sort of try to convey a lot
um in an economy of words so there are a
lot of ways to read what are police for
you know one is to do what elizabeth did
which is to say
well what have they been for what are
they for right now
um and i co-sign everything she just
said
you know another way of thinking about
it is to be forward-looking
and to say when we were asking that
question what are the police for we're
talking about in the new era in a new
vision in a place
we're really trying to um think of
safety
you know the provision of safety by the
state um
as as a public good well what role do
police
what are police for in in that world
understanding that police might not look
anything like the policing service that
as it exists today
that it is not necessary when i'm asking
what are police for i'm not asking
what are armed general purpose chained
for um first responders for although
there might be
a role for some of those people in
in some context actually
um but you know when i'm talking about
democratic policing
i'd like to you know and i wrote that
before
you know we gwen finished our piece on
protect and serve and you know
i've been writing a bunch of things you
know all all summer about this
it's important to distinguish the police
service as it exists today
from the concept of policing
as a public good as an instantiation
of a fully realized
reconstruction of the police power and
in that context you know i want to use
reconstruction capital r
right um because if you know if you take
a
a
historical through line in all of this
um the communities
and i think kovid provides a the coven
pandemic that we're living through
um provides a very good example that the
communities that
are experiencing all the violence that i
just spoke of
in new haven as well as violence in the
police response
are the same communities that are
experiencing higher rates of covet
infection
and higher rates of death and higher
rates
of maternal fetal death
and higher rates of low educational
attainment
and you know higher rates of lead
poisoning we can go on
which is a result of decades of
disinvestment in these communities
over time which we've known for a very
long time but
concretely when the kerner commission's
report
was made public right and we haven't
done
anything um about that which connects up
with what elizabeth was saying
about the tax structure right and so in
that context
um you know when i think about abolition
you know and i wrote in 2017
in the boston review policing as we know
it must be abolished before it can be
transformed it is useful
to connect that conversation um the
abolition conversation
with reconstruction
and think about that aborted
project a project that was aborted by
white supremacist violence
right um and think about that
in the context of where we started this
conversation
which is what does it mean to achieve
community
vitality right to my mind
a reconstruction project is necessary
for that and a reconstruction project
that not only centers community but
acknowledges
the necessity of state support
this is not a private project it's not
private
and people deserve the support of the
state
they deserve it and i for one
am going to be spending the next 10
years before i retire and yes i am going
to retire in 10 years
thank you both um and now i'm gonna turn
over to questions from the audience so
if you have any questions please
send those my way um i have
uh i'm gonna start first um
well i'll start with this question for
tracy because you've
touched upon it a bit more but can you
say more this is from professor goldsby
about the governance problem
what does that encompass and why is it
prodigious
and then kind of the second part of that
question
is how might we quote recovering
positive police power
break the log jams that federalism and
or governance
create yeah like that's such a
long thing but let me just give you a
couple examples
just to say there's just not as much
especially with respect
to safety as we think about it in the
policing context
that can be done at the federal level as
people think
right it's just not a thing that
can happen right in the same way that
you know the federal gov the federal
government actually because of the way
it's grown up has more
ability to mandate educational standards
right now than it does
to create national standards
for how policing agencies should
operate so when you're trying to figure
out what to do
you either use the federal government to
provide technical
technical assistance and resources at
the agency level
or you try to figure out some way to
mandate to to incentivize states to
mandate
agencies to do it and that's a difficult
project
and we don't have a ton of time but like
i can give you very specific examples
of how to do that like you know i i've
proposed
to the current administration like ways
you can do it
um but it's hard and it requires
congressional approval so that if you
don't have
democratic majorities in in both houses
it's hard to do
you can't do it by executive order i
mean there are all these things
um that are are really tough
to do so when you talk about the
you know the positive project you know
the the strategy that
we have been uh adopting for the last
several years has been to sort of think
about it agency by agency using
demonstration projects
using kind of natural competition among
these folks to be like oh i want to be
like eric jones in stockton i mean you
know that only gets you so far
um you can try
to work at the state level to pass
certain legislation
for minimum standards
but legislators have to be motivated
most most
state legislators are are par part-time
and they're not experts they don't have
staffs like the federal government does
and so
there's a different role that
organizations like
let's say the justice collaboratory
might be able to play
in producing model legislation but then
of course we can't lobby so how are we
going to get the legislation passed like
that's the kind of stuff that i mean
you know and i'm about to be wonky but
it's a wonky wonk
problem it's a super wonky wonk problem
is there anything you'd like to add to
that elizabeth or can i follow up with
another question thank you tracy
okay so this is an interdisciplinary
question for you elizabeth
which is that if rank and file police
think that knowing history
doesn't help them do police work
would learning something like political
science
be more effective in their work
yeah i think it's i think unfortunately
it's less of a
um it's not about an aversion to history
but i think
more about an aversion to um
having discussions about racism and
um and and having discussions about um
uh the nature of inequality and so
you know whether whether we approach
that from a political science or
sociological or historical framework
um i think that that is is primarily
what
what they are adverse to and um
you know this is not true across the
board right but some of what i've heard
is that
um and this is you know kind of a more
specific example of what i was getting
at but that um
that because that that because of the
kind of emphasis on um systemic racism
in police departments uh police have
kind of like shied away from the issue
altogether and have argued that you know
like they have and this is part of the
um this is part of you know some of some
of
what especially conservative pundits
have have used to explain the ferguson
effect that
basically like following um uprising
that police
retreat because they're they're worried
that if they make arrests or if they
if they do their jobs that they're going
to be called a racist or that anything
that they do is somehow racist so so
part of it is you know that there is an
aversion to
addressing these issues head on and you
know from
from even the the procedural justice and
um
module historic historical module
trainings and stocks into the command
college that i was talking about i mean
nine out of ten officers will say well i
don't see color
you know i don't see color i'm not
racist yes that might have happened you
know
50 years ago but like that's not that's
that's not how i do my job
um i'm colorblind and so it's you know
when when that's the premise it takes
a lot of work and discussion to even
kind of begin to peel back where you can
begin to
open people to to being receptive
um to understanding these kind of like
larger historical
and political dynamics um at stake
can i just add one thing to that which
is police are not unique
right right so and i think that's
important to understand
right they are not singular in any way
um you know there are plenty people that
i deal with on a day-to-day basis at
this university who are no different
from that
uh it's just that
the the cost of their aversion to it
is much greater um but you know
many of us on this zoom call probably
have kids in school and stuff
you know think about the teachers you
deal with
um you know we we all encounter people
in various versions
of that so i think that piece
is worth saying and and it's also an
opportunity for me to lift up another
one of our colleagues at the justice
collaboratory jen richardson
um who's a social psychologist who
studies this phenomenon it's
universal so we should be clear about
that
um what something that's coming up in
that point about
you know there are so many people
who in so many different roles who are
participating
in racialized surveillance whether
they're an educator
um a social worker um
or like i relatively been
even like benign roles where they may
not even be
interacting with too many people so
something that i am
thinking about um in reference to the
work that you're doing
elizabeth with police with police
departments and educating them on
history
i'm thinking about the local kind of
grassroots political education that's
been taking place
in cities across the u.s so teaching
community community members or also kind
of
harvesting the knowledge within and
historical
you know memory within the communities
about um
the historic role of of police and state
violence and surveillance
and how that local knowledge has
maybe a particularly transformative role
because of the
spatially situated um
this is a bit of a ramble but i'm
thinking about that spatial situation
the work that you know memory can do
on the local level but then kind of
these acute barriers as you've mentioned
tracy
at this this at the you know municipal
county state and federal level and you
know what do we
what what kind of meaning might we make
about
um you know this growth and political
education
and coinciding poli mobilization
um amid a lot of governance barriers
yeah i just
wonder if you can comment on that a
little bit
well i think just briefly i mean it's a
great question and it speaks to the
moment that we're in and it's a reminder
that
you know i mean we've been talking a lot
and many of
um most of our discussion has really
been centered on the police and law
enforcement but that doesn't mean that
like
you know that that that's going to be
the agent for change right history
and particularly black history teaches
us that
you know it is about organizing it is
about political education
that it takes time um that it's not like
an instant thing
and that you know we've got to
continually
put pressure on the state in order to
bring about the changes that we'd like
to see so i think um
i think that's what's so exciting about
this moment is that you know we just
witnessed and
and this again gets to the the um the
comments you know how how professor
goldsby opened up this whole discussion
um the stakes are very clear they've
never been higher we just witnessed
what's being called the largest uh mass
movement in u.s history for
anything um but it was premise around
the idea of racial justice and social
justice
and i think it's up to us to keep this
momentum
going um because it's not you know what
history shows
is that you know policy makers um
and police chiefs and police unions
they're not gonna make
changes they're not gonna make any
reform out of the goodness of their
heart
it takes pressure um and it's up to us
to keep that
that pressure on and i think you know um
i mean that's part of what's been what
has been so important about some of the
this moment
and the technological advance of of the
the last
15 years or so right because or five
years even
um because it's not as if this police
violence is new
it's just that and it's not as if black
communities where this police violence
happened weren't aware of it it's just
that it has been so localized
um and now i mean really beginning with
rodney king in 91
um the nation and white people in
particular have been
are now witness to this violence and as
that the kind of like onslaught of that
has
continued to pace um especially you know
during uh barack obama's second term
we've seen the the kind the mobilization
grow and so i think now that we have
you know everybody has their camera in
their pocket
we're beginning to build this kind of
documentary evidence that can that has
outraged people um so that now you know
most
most americans according to polling do
think there needs to be some kind of
policing reform most americans
um support the idea of black lives
matter and want to see racial justice
this is unprecedented and so it's
um so i think the public is becoming
more educated
and we need to to continue that
education and keep the pressure on which
is why
again i think you know it's really
exciting to be
here at yale and part of the justice
collaboratory in this moment because
it does feel like and it's not going to
be easy it's going to be a lot of work
we may not see it um you know in our
lifetime i don't know tracy it may not
fully happen by the time you retire uh
but you know it we we are beginning to
churn out something new
um that hopefully will finally
um learn from and move beyond
the left you know the lessons that we
now know of all of the failed approaches
and all of the oppressive and repressive
measures
um that have shaped uh
dynamics of inequality and of um
of police community relations
historically
tracy do you want to add anything
that was good and yeah i know it's not
happening before i retire but i'm still
retiring
um to to follow up on this
this piece about time um momentum
and unprecedented support and then
situating
kind of relating this moment to
what seemed like a similarly pivotal
moment post
um kerner commission um
elizabeth i i wonder
if based on your wisdom as a historian
and as an activist scholar if you could
talk a bit
about what what is it gonna take
to to kind of
shirk that historical path right
particularly
um of ensuring that that liberals white
liberal policy makers
do not um do not shy away
from the the the urgent and thought and
you know historically situated um and
um you know demands of community members
right now
that's another really big question i
mean i think you know and it's not
and this is something that like my new
research um has really
made clear to me you know the kerner
commission was like the biggest
post-riot commission but in many
of the cities that experienced that kind
of violence you know that they had like
civil rights commissions or human
relations commissions
of their own many of which were kind of
modeled on the kerner commission
many of or all of which you know pointed
attention to the specific
socio-economic conditions in locale and
in various locales
like the krannert commission you know um
recognized the role of white racism but
also like the current commission was
very limited in terms of
um its kind of pathological and racist
assumptions
about um about poor black americans
about the nature of black poverty
um about black criminal criminality
stemming um
you know from ideas about criminal black
criminality historically but
um you know really kind of taking hold
in a new and important way following
moynihan's report so i think one of the
things you know we don't need
having said that um we don't the
the kind of impulse after um
these moments of police violence is to
you know start a commissioner or put
together a task force and we don't
necessarily need
another kind of national task force to
study the problem of inequality and then
you know essentially do an update to the
kerner commission's recommendations
which is saying we need a marshall plan
for american cities we need a different
kind of investments
that would go beyond the war on poverty
um
and i think you know having said that
that's that's what's needed we know
what's needed
these demands have been made and these
recommendations have been made over and
over and over again
now for you know more than a half
century um and it's time to actually do
it
um and you know as i just said
like you know i'm hopeful we're gonna do
it it's gonna take a lot of work but
it's also
i think that um that you know the
the the recent election was really
humbling because
um you know we have a lot i mean it's
not just you know political education
in um the communities that are kind of
like ground zero for this policing
this kind of policing but it's like
political education throughout the
united states because
you know the fact is that donald trump
uh
got the second highest number of votes
for any presidential
candidate in u.s history 74 million
people voted for donald trump i mean we
see it now in the georgia runoff
election
where you know it's basically based on
do you want these radical
socialists anarchists to take over and
implement a green new deal and take your
rights away and take police away and all
of these things so
we i mean i think a lot of us recognize
that that what it's going to take is a
major structural intervention
and changing tax structure you know many
of the things that we mentioned
um but that is going to be you know the
process of actually realizing that
is going to be substantial so we don't
need to begin that process by continuing
um to study the problem i do think
having said that and
um tracy and i are on um i was like what
are you talking about why are we doing
that thing
we are on a task force right now at the
national academy is um
that's looking at that but that's
looking specifically at racial disparity
see
that is something that's new that has
not been done you know there has not
really been a task force
that is that that is seeking to um study
and identify specifically
the racial disparities within the
justice system that wasn't an objective
of the criminal commission that wasn't
an
objective of any of the um commissions
that i've seen or studied and i think
one step towards meaningful change is
really documenting the ways in which
policing and the criminal legal system
in the united states um targets
uh people of color and has exacerbated
racial
inequality and so you know identifying i
think centering racism
in that discussion is a necessary way to
achieve change
but we don't need you know we don't we
know that what we need is a structural
transformation and so
um you know we need to work towards
building that rather than continuing to
study
that problem um racism is something that
you know and again
my experience working with um with
police in california demonstrates is
something that
we still have a long way to go and i
think that the um
you know again the the support uh
for white extremism that we have seen
really on you know not that it ever went
away but really on
very visible display in recent months um
shows just how far we have to go in
order to
to become a truly um racially
egalitarian
nation so
how do i want to intervene um i don't
mean intervene as and
i disagree with anything that you said i
just like to say something useful as we
are getting to the end of this
conversation so i think the place that i
want to build on is this idea of
um structure and
juxtapose it against um
the idea of rights which
has been sort of the fundamental way
of trying to push forward um on these
on these topics right um and
and i think given if you tie the
structure and rights conversation to the
point about federalism
you understand the ways in which
identifying certain outcomes that you
want you know like
the kerner commission says people need
all of these things all right
let's say we had said okay people have
rights to those things
right then the question is how is it
that
their that government is actually going
to make good
on um giving people
the material resources they need for
those rates you know to effectuate those
those those rights and and it's
interesting elizabeth that you mentioned
voting because i just read
a book yesterday and draft by a law
professor gee charles
uriel and his co-author luis fuentes
and um you know when you think about the
voting rights act you have to understand
that
the united states constitution actually
does not give
people a constitutional right to vote
that is actually provided
at the state level and when you look at
the ways in which the federal government
has supported or not supported
that you know on the one hand we see
that this election was sort of fraud and
it felt too close and all of those
people voted for this person that
you know is essentially king george um
if you read the declaration of
independence
as i did last night about 80 percent
of the complaints against king george
actually apply to
the person who is president of the
united states right now
which is an interesting exercise but uh
in any case right because we don't have
a federalist
like a national context for effectuation
of these outcomes to which we want to
give people rights
it basically points up the demand for
changing the structure
of it right you know that is you know if
we could
actually get universal voting and made
that meaningful structurally
which in some sense requires upending
federalism
um i i hope i'm not being too elliptical
you know i'd love to share gi's chapters
with you if
and which makes this point very clear um
then you'd see
that there's actually a path perhaps to
achieving the things
that we have long known are necessary
and and that's a it ends up being kind
of a procedural justice
point in a sense because
you know you need a
in in the way that democratic governance
works in this country you need a path
you need a process for effectuation of
these
substantive rights to which people want
to have access and people care a lot
about that
we know that from the social psychology
work
people care about having access to
certain processes
in order to you know make meaning of
their their role in society but just we
also know
as a as just a a mechanical
matter that's how you get
this done right that's where power
and you know and governance meet
in terms of getting people what
they want and need i hope that made
sense
thank you both for um i think that that
last question just
underscored you know how
much um how much we need
this revolution um how much it is
going it is a reconstructive process um
that requires um an energy an
interdisciplinary
space like um the african-american
studies department that's leading with
colloquial
colloquium and the justice collaboratory
that's doing similar work from
from a policy perspective we have
out we're completely out of time and
i just uh want to thank uh
thank you both professor hinton
professor mears
um stressor femster and and professor
goldbe for convening us
um i'm so grateful to have the chance to
be in conversation with you today
and i wish everybody
a healthy and safe
remainder of 2020.
i thank you so much thank you tracy
thank you gwen
yeah thank you thank you you're you were
wonderful my dear
i think thank you